dramatische Bilder erreichen uns in
diesen Tagen aus der Türkei und Syrien
10.000 Menschen sind bei dem Erdbeben
umgekommen und jetzt gilt es den
Überlebenden zu helfen denn ansonsten
droht die Katastrophe nach der
Katastrophe alijan aus Essen ist sie
aktiv geworden und das auf eine sehr
persönliche Art und Weise sein
Engagement gilt eigentlich dem
Alltagsrassismus und genau der
verhindert jetzt in der Türkei die Hilfe
für viele Menschen Alisan will genau
dagegen jetzt etwas tun los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und vielen Dank an
Fabian Griff hat ihn habe ich gefragt ob
er jemand kennt der sich persönlich
engagiert und er sagte es gibt
verschiedene seriöse Stellen an die man
aktuell spenden kann ich möchte dir
meinen guten Freund Alican empfehlen
seine Familie ist selbst betroffen von
den Erdbeben und er sammelt mit seiner
Stiftung dem viel Respekt Zentrum
Spenden die definitiv ankommen ja und so
sieht es jetzt in der Heimat von alijan
aus
also die haben sowohl ganz viel Schaden
an dem Häuser
im Zelt als auch Tote und ich will nicht
wissen wie es Familien gibt die ganz
viele truth haben oder vielleicht Papa
die Mutter die Kinder verloren haben
Gräber soweit das Auge reicht doch die
meisten Familienmitglieder von alijan
sind glimpflicht davon gekommen also
meine Oma ähm ist mit meinen Tanten
momentan in einem Zelt ich habe mit den
gestern länger telefoniert ähm die haben
seit vorgestern Heizkörper im Zelt
das heißt vorher war den einfach super
kalt meine Oma hat das versucht noch so
ein bisschen mild auszudrücken aber ich
konnte aus der Stimme raushören dass die
echt gefroren haben also auch die ersten
drei Tage haben die im Auto geschlafen
zu fünft und ab und zu so alle zwei drei
Stunden sind alle aufgemacht haben jetzt
Auto angebracht damit es ein bisschen
warm wird weil da war Schnee also jetzt
wird zwar gerade ein bisschen wärmer
wieder aber das ist eisig und das ist
wirklich
ja greifbar und diesen Menschen zu
helfen darum geht es jetzt denn wenn sie
keine Nahrung und keine Unterkunft
bekommen droht eben die Katastrophe nach
der Katastrophe also ich bin stets unter
Strom ich organisiert parallel einen
LKW-Transport dann bereiten wir das
nächste Benefizkonzert vor also viel am
Arbeiten und gleichzeitig immer mit
einem Ohr bei meinen Verwandten in der
Türkei ich habe viele verwandt ich bin
selber in Südosten geboren in der Stadt
die jetzt der wüstet ist denn das ist
wichtig dass jetzt Menschen wie aligan
helfen die sich zum einen in der Region
auskennen und die die Menschen kennen
und zweitens Hilfe auch organisieren
können es kommen also Gruppen auf mich
zu und sagen hey wir haben jetzt Hilfen
wir sind aber Privatperson ihr habt doch
eine gemeinsame Stiftung was kann man
tun das heißt ich versuche mit unserer
Stiftung jetzt diese Hilfe leisten darf
ja Aktion so koordinieren und zu stellen
damit wir Spenden sammeln dann steht was
neues dazu das heißt ja organisieren
Spenden an dem Erklärung ab dem Texte
schreiben
und vor allem mit der Türkei viel in
Kontakt sein damit wir immer wissen
damit der Puls sind wissen wo müssen die
Bedarf werden wo müssen die hilfsküttern
was wird gebraucht weil die Lage ist
sehr kompliziert und das heißt ich bin
stets am Newsticker und am Kommunizieren
und am Handy ich habe steht seine
Powerbank dabei und
zu sprechen
arbeitet mit seiner viel Respekt
Stiftung hier in Deutschland eigentlich
gegen den Alltagsrassismus und genau der
begegnet ihm jetzt auch vor Ort und dann
hat man nichts Gutes über die
Katastrophenschutzbehörde vor Ort das
Gilten an bestimmten Gebiete noch nicht
gekommen sind also es gibt auch sehr
viel Brust und gut auch verschiedene
marktführere und ja deswegen also
einfach sehr viele Probleme auf einmal
also das ist super unverständlich also
unverständlich weil für mich ich es lö
schotteln aus
das ist auch einer der Gründe warum ich
mit unserer Stiftung und mit anderen
Vereinen in Deutschland aktiv bin weil
wir sehen dass die Leute eben nicht zu
also immer zusammenhalten dass das ist
Rassismus gibt der Staat hat die Aufgabe
allen zu helfen und es sollte auch und
das sollte nicht Gebiete auslachen aber
es passiert und deswegen müssen wir umso
eher aktiv sein also Rassismus ist ein
weltweites Phänomen und das macht sich
in allen Bereichen bemerkbar als jetzt
auch in der Katastrophenhilfe deshalb
veranstaltet Alisan jetzt
Benefizkonzerte und tut alles unmöglich
viele Spenden zusammen um den vielen
vielen Betroffenen dort jetzt zu helfen
die von der Katastrophenhilfe
ausgeschlossen werden ihr könnt Teil
seiner Aktion werden indem er ihn dabei
unterstützt ein Benefizkonzert besucht
oder einfach spendet mehr Informationen
gibt es hier oder in der
Videobeschreibung einfach draufklicken
er freut sich über alles was hilft
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt